i actually do cuss a little do you also
what's your favorite curse word probably
that's josh peck impersonating his tv
sister miranda cosgrove on tick tock i'm
excited i actually do cuss a little do
you also what's your favorite curse word
probably
now what exactly prompted the 35 year
old actor to act out this impression it
all started when this interview with the
icarly star went viral i actually do
cuss a little do you also what's your
favorite curse word
with the interview trending it makes
sense josh would want to get in on the
fun it's really cool
the drake and josh starr has a long
history with the 28 year old actress
miranda played josh's stepsister megan
parker on the hit nickelodeon series
everyone hates me because of you i
wanted one piece of cake
not you professor dorkstein
what are you talking about i just got
thrown out of a party because you gave
us a pop quiz that we all failed all
right you failed the pop quiz welcome to
my club
the two are reuniting again for season
two of the icarly revival did you want
icarly to be the most successful web
series in history or did you want it to
just be like a massive failure i mean
probably the most successful web series
in history duh last year the school of
rock star opened up to et about making
the revival for the fans when we first
got the call about possibly doing the
revival jerry and nathan and i all
thought it was really important that
we really made the show for the original
fans and the people that are now in
their early 20s or teenagers or late 20s
anybody that really enjoyed the show
from before we put in a lot of like
easter eggs and fun things now it seems
like there's a lot of love between
miranda and josh but there's a more
complicated history between him and his
former on-screen bro drake bell
presumably stemming from josh's decision
to not invite drake to his wedding in
2017.
at the time drake tweeted that he was
hurt by the move but just a few months
later the pair seemingly buried the
hatchet and reunited is this happening
right now live as we is this really
right now live stream right now oh my
god wait is this streaming to be nice to
me oh my god this is not even mike
just don't facebook listen listen lay
off thank you you hear that facebook
it's all chill out we love you off man
fast forward to 2022 and josh is opening
up on the bff podcast revealing the real
reason why drake wasn't included in his
nuptials so i get married to my wife and
the dirty little secret i guess was like
i knew that drake and i didn't stay in
touch for the 10 years since we had made
the show so i didn't invite him in my
wedding because i hadn't really talked
to him in many many years
cut to i'm getting married that night
and i see these text messages from him
like
cursing me out coming from me i'm like
on the night of my wedding and i'm like
yo and it's delusional because i'm like
bro it's like we worked at coffee dean
when we were 16 like i'm sorry i'm 31
now i might have lost your number
[Music]